Malia and Sasha by the way are thankful
that this is my final presidential
turkey pardon
President Obama continued the
long-standing presidential tradition of
pardoning a turkey at the White House on
Wednesday but the commander in chief had
everyone laughing by revealing his
daughters Sasha and Malia aren't the
biggest fans of the annual ceremony for
the past seven years I've established
another tradition embarrassing my
daughters with a cornucopia of dad jokes
about turkeys this year they had a
scheduling conflict actually they just
couldn't take my jokes anymore what I
haven't told them yet is that we are
gonna do this every year from now on no
way I'm cutting this habit cold turkey
instead President Obama brought out his
two nephews in place of his daughters
the White House revealed on Twitter that
two turkeys attended the ceremony tater
and topped and after polling several
citizens they tweeted tottaly pleased to
announce the People's Choice for the
2016 national Thanksgiving turkey hash
tag team tot